you have we have knight edge too yeah
that does oh he is
gaining more time somehow or perhaps he
is actually avoiding the position with
the knight on h2 pushing back the king
pretty much
somehow no okay whatever king g3
never
i like the
the never part of the programming oh
he is going for it
going forward maybe it's just repeating
but he's not going for anything yeah
he's just gaining time even though he
has three minutes in this position
um
rugby three
very hard to take a pawn from ikaro even
if you're a pizza
might h2 and then rook c5 and then
probably at that point you call it quits
i would assume
it is the last game of
hiki j 101 if wesley wins and wesley
will win so
five played king g6
wesley is gaining space here with that
yeah the b point king g5
so fancy
yeah
some options
i also do like king h3 intending rook b5
f4
checkmate that also looks pretty are we
blundering some kind of a stalemate it's
difficult to understand very hard
and wesley does win hikaro